nous sommes devant le centre commercial
vélizy 2 à vélizy villacoublay dans les
yvelines s'il n'y a pas foule derrière
moi au centre de dépistage antico vide
c'est parce que depuis quelques jours il
n'est plus obligatoire de présenter un
pass sanitaires pour accéder au centre
commercial
décision du tribunal administratif de
versailles qui a suspendu l'arrêté
préfectoral concernant l'obligation du
passani terre dans les grands centres
commerciaux décision de justice
similaire dans l'essonne et le haut rhin
selon la justice s'est arrêté ne
permettent pas en effet de garantir un
accès libre aux biens de première
nécessité
les mesures de restrictions imposées par
le préfet du haut-rhin s'applique de
façon générale et absolue à l'ensemble
des commerces situés dans les grands
magasins et centres commerciaux liste et
elle ne prévoit aucun aménagement
permettant de réserver l'accès des
personnes ne disposant pas de passes
sanitaires aux établissements
commercialisant des biens de première
nécessité dans l'enceinte de ses
magasins et centres en particulier aux
commerces alimentaires en seine saint
denis douze centres commerciaux sont
concernées par l'obligation du pass
sanitaires à l'entrée quatre particulier
chez le syndicat cgt 93 ont saisi le
tribunal administratif de montreuil pour
contester l'arrêté préfectoral en
question ils ont pour leur part reçu une
fin de non recevoir de la part de la
justice la requête ne tenait compte ni
de la situation sanitaire ni de
l'intérêt de santé publique et de la
lutte contre la propagation de
l'épidémie de kobe 19 ce n'est peut-être
que partie remise après des victoires
dans les yvelines et l'essonne l'avocate
arrêt corail thème en charge du dossier
estime que la mesure de suspension
devrait être appliquée partout sur le
territoire il ne peut pas y avoir une
différence de traitement entre les
habitants de plusieurs départements je
vais déposer un recours devant le
tribunal administratif de paris
des suspensions en cascade synonyme de
véritable camouflet pour le gouvernement
et qui compte bien faire appel de ces
décisions de justice on a décidé de
faire appel de ces décisions parce qu'on
considère que le pass sanitaire doit
continuer à s'appliquer pour le moment
dans les lieux dans lesquels il était
prévu il était aussi prévu que le pass
sanitaire disparaissent au 15 novembre
mais le gouvernement pourrait en décider
autrement ça pourrait arriver si le coc
vide ne disparaissaient pas de nos vies
dans les trois prochains mois les
derniers réticents sont en train de
tomber face au succès du pass and i ter
faut dire qu'il ya peut-être une forme
de dénicher le ministre de la santé qui
refuse d'admettre les nombreuses
procédures judiciaires et les
manifestations massives contre le pass
sanitaires qui ont lieu chaque week end
depuis le mois de juillet